no take care of Mount salabat let's go
with efore okay let's try this I've been
doing a lot of nights III closed
Sicilian but let's enter this territory
it's a veteran a cop Sicilian might we
see or not maybe Dragonland
Sicilian Dragonland now that is
different that is definitely different
right there um what do you do here well
my first thought is just keep going
Bishop c4 is my opponent looking to take
my knight and then play there Bishop to
c6
hmm or should I look to play f4 well
actually what's wrong with just Bishop
here no I'm gonna go offer the more
aggressive I may not want to just go for
a queenside castle so I think I might
want to go with a quick King side castle
and then something like f4 f5 maybe some
Bishop g5 thrown in between ok this is
well we're entering by transposition
what are we entering what is happening
here dragon variation by transposition
push it back and now yeah where this is
clearly just dragon territory by a
little bit of a move order F 3 stops
Knight here allows for Queen d2
queenside castle so start it a little
bit weird with the quick deployment of
those Queen side pieces now it's gonna
get wild or maybe I could prevent it
from getting wild and enter into a
column or territory so we have what's
known as the Yugoslav attack going on
queenside castle run H pun run forest
h5 engage if I'm gonna castle on the
Queen side we're out to kill one
anothers King let's give it a shot
here we go all in the chips are pushed
all in let's go all in these games
usually finish quick okay do I say you
know what let's go g4 takes h5 I like 95
instead actually gonna go with that this
is a more positional approach but and
don't interpret that is like well it's
just gonna end up in a draw I think I
still maintain an edge I have a still
lead in development slight very slight
and I have well my opponents in a pin
lapel play rook c8 but I have this to be
biting out h5 with this g4 move I wonder
if I should take here with my bishop and
then have the bishop recapture and then
play g4 i don't want this night getting
to this square I think I'm actually
gonna try that it's interesting I'm
gonna give that a shot just so I can get
in this G form of a bit
easier they're crazy to give up their
dark square bishop and by the way this
is like a number-one priority as black
you want to hang on to this guy or you
will suffer defeat quickly quickly
this is G file opening up this King is
gonna get sliced up really quick without
this bishop around he is a number one
defender fork castle position your
dragon Bishop the dragon Bishop is on g7
the one that has been fiend cut up
beware
he's a tough guy yes the bishops are
three when they're off the board but in
this position right here this guy is
like five he is worth a beefy five
points so let's chop and then play here
right this bishop I like that the bishop
is getting in the way of the rook even
having direct sight of this pawn so if
he's the number if he's the number one
guy here and let's get rid of him if he
goes the King goes I think it comes down
to that let's give it a shot so I have
an open file group g1 is gonna be a good
move of the two rooks this is probably
the better one the one in the corner is
doing nothing and now Bishop here is
threatening Queen here which is lethal
in fact I think it's already one now
right I don't see a defense Queen h6 is
just a killer it's a killer so that was
a pretty clean approach all right Queen
h6 filed by a rook here on the G file
with check his lights out it's a me
coming up
I was a little bit of a clearance in
fact in that position instead of doing
the bishop deform move my first thought
was actually Bishop to g5 but you know
the same idea challenged the bishop but
you know how have a strong a stronger
threat in mind as well
Queen age six all right good game no
thanks let's see let me go a little
slower that one good good game to my
opponent whose name is no thanks that
could be interpreted a different way
let's have a look it's very easy to just
get killed quickly I know that there's a
better way to be putting up a real well
I'm sure there's a better way to be
putting up resistance let's see how we
could do that so okay yeah again it's it
turns out to be the Yugoslavia tack or
yeah Yugoslav attack but slight
transposition now we're back on familiar
turf I wonder if a six is um should be
played here I wonder if there's
something more direct so yeah I think
maybe still going with the main line
I like rook to ca and knight Knight e5
to c4 I think this is turning out to
just be a waste of time I have seen
sometimes just b5 without the a6 support
so keep that in mind
right there
you know just leave b5 giving up on just
to open up lines towards my king III
queenside castle so just just do a move
you'll probably end up doing anyhow in
other words like rook c8 and probably
come there anyhow and then if I play
queenside castle there might even again
there might even be b5 move or something
or a five it might even be a five
involved I think maybe even a t5 could
be a move it's not without weakening b5
but something tells me a six could
there's an improvement upon that right
there and in such a dynamic opening as
this you really do have to make every
move cow and that could already be
translating into a downfall right there
so yeah and maybe I'm just not sure I
don't know about these are a and B pawn
pushes so I'm thinking still trying with
the main line because I'm liking my
position here a lot I think this is
maybe a good idea that I went forward
with and there there's not many choices
that you have I'm already engaging with
your pawns and it's too difficult to get
at my King I don't I don't see really
how he be getting at my King anytime
soon so I think the adjustment is back
at this point right here with these a6
is a6 and b5 idea go with rook c8 95 and
then this pivot on the c-4 square I take
you take with your rook and then getting
your queen out to a5 this is a common
move to see work out our queen out to a
5 maybe even right now actually Queen d2
there might even be Queen Queen a5 and
then you look on f2 see a sometimes you
will want to maybe make use of the c8
square with your King Brooke so as to
make so as to meet a move like Bishop h6
with tucking the bishop back to h8
avoids the bishop exchange whereas
otherwise there might be you know
if they're if it's this rook that's here
Bishop h6 if the bishop backs up it's
not without having to give up some
material and I've even seen something
like that played before where you know
you give up the exchange but you
maintain this dragon bishop so anyhow
some things to know from that